hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
when we're examining franz fanon's book
black skin
white masks as a whole as a piece of
literature
and as a work of philosophy although
at a certain point he says it's rather
psychology than philosophy we'll get to
that in a moment
we can talk about an overall approach
which has several dimensions or elements
to it woven together
and this is not something that is is
dissociated
from its overall argument the overall
case that he is making throughout the
work and this is
in some respects a challenging work
because of that many people would like
there to be a method
or an approach and then you just apply
it to the phenomena and he says no no
there's a dialectic going on
and as a matter of fact as he is is
writing this work it's developing
as a whole by applying these these
different things and finding out how
they
interpret each other affect each other
give a more and more adequate
overall picture you could say and if
we're gonna
you know say that there's two main
let's call them orientations or or
vectors
we could say there's there's
psychoanalysis and then there's
existentialism but it's also good to
remember that these are not
too totally separate very well-defined
movements or anything there's a lot of
inner penetration between them
and in somebody like fanon we find these
being used
um quite a bit in in conjunction with
each other and being theorized in that
way
so we can talk about this psychoanalytic
approach and you know this is there from
the very
beginning he talks about this as an
effort to understand what he calls the
black white relation which turns out to
be quite
complex and so we should look at a few
of the things that he says
early on in his introduction as a matter
of fact this is one that i'm really
every time i read it i'm i'm drawn by
this
he says this book should have been
written three years ago but these truths
were a fire in me
then now i can tell them without being
burned
these truths do not have to be hurled in
men's faces they are not intended to
ignite fervor i do not trust
fervor and he says fervor is the weapon
of choice of the
omnipotence so there's a it's not just
supposed to be a
throw something in everybody's face and
say see racism
so bad or anything like that he's doing
a careful
analysis here and he's also saying
listen we can't just beat people over
the head with this we have to
make a case and then let people if
they're able to
you know see whether that that case
works or not or not and so
he talks about this complex problematic
structure and what is it well it's a
it's a relation between
black and white and you might say well
that's very universal and there is a
universal aspect to it but
there's also a lot of particular aspects
so
he goes in and he says um if we examine
uh things in the course of this essay we
are going to observe the development of
an effort to understand the black white
relation
the white man is sealed in his whiteness
the black man
in his blackness just a little bit
earlier than that he says
the black man wants to be white the
white man slaves to reach a
human level so he's not saying that you
know blacks
you know as a universal class
are stuck in this this position whites
are stuck in this position
everybody's kind of stuck everybody is
is is in this framed relation to each
other where there's a great
you know amount of potential freedom to
be exercised
but when we're not careful we shift back
into these quite easily so he says
we're going to ascertain the directions
and now notice the word that he uses
here of this dual
narcissism and the motivations that
inspire it
and we should pause on that what would
he mean a dual narcissism
so to be narcissistic is a
a personality problem
right and you know in his time they use
the word neurosis
now we use disorder or you know other
language depending on on who's
psychology we're adopting and the idea
is that the narcissist
is sort of obsessed with their own
situation
and unable to grasp that of others
except in relation to their
their own the others don't really have
importance as
such but we can also be in sort of a
dual narcissism
where you know this is what we call
codependency
in in interpersonal relations these days
where
each person is getting something out of
the situation
that they're in on some level i mean
it's not it's not necessarily getting
something in in the sense of like
getting
actually what they truly want but
they're forced into it
and so that's good to to keep in mind
so he says at the beginning of my
speculations it seems
inappropriate to elaborate the
conclusions the reader will find
concern with the elimination of a
vicious circle has been the only
guideline for my effort so that tells
you what he's
what he's about here this is not just a
book of analysis
this is a book that's supposed to
provide a way
out so he says there is a fact white men
consider
themselves superior to black men there's
another fact black men want to prove to
white men at all cost the richness of
their thought
the equal value of their intellect how
do
we extricate ourselves so he's not
saying
how do we win how do we decide who's got
it right
how do we get out of this this bind and
see so he says
i believe only a psychoanalytical
interpretation of the black problem can
lay bear the anomalies of affect that
are responsible for the structure
of the complex
and he says the analysis i'm undertaking
is psychological
in spite of this is apparent to me the
effective disalienation of the black man
entails an immediate recognition
of he says what social
and economic realities if there is an
inferiority complex
it is the outcome of a double process
now he says
what is this double process primarily
economic and this is why his analysis
here
applies not just to french colonies
but to racism more generally when we
look at racism carefully
we find out that there's always an
economic component
involved in contemporary modern racism
right there's actually a whole bunch of
economic components
then he says subsequently the
internalization or better the
epidermalization of this inferiority
and then he goes into some discussion
about freud which we'll get to
shortly so there's this complex
problematic structure
he mentions this at a couple other
points as well
that are worth bringing up he uh
says that here we go he's talking about
people in
madagascar and the the
analysis by a psychoanalyst that he
thinks
has gotten wrong he says
[Music]
here we go in other words i begin to
suffer from not being a white man to the
degree that the white man imposes
discrimination on me makes me a
colonized native
robs me of all worth all individuality
tells me i'm a parasite on the world
that i must bring myself as quickly as
possible and step with the white world
he goes on and he says then i will
simply try to make myself white that is
to compel the white man to acknowledge
that i am human
but this doesn't work and monony the
person who who fonon is criticizing says
oh it's because you have a dependency
complex
and fanon says no the answer is much
more simpler
you're not going to get the white world
to acknowledge you
as an equal and it doesn't have to do
with your own inferiority complex that
has been
placed upon you so there's again
this this structure is rearing its head
just a little bit
after that he says um
here we go when i'm uh
you know looking at things in terms of
my patience he says my patient is
suffering from an inferiority complex
if he's overwhelmed to such a degree by
the wish to be white it is because
he lives in a society that makes his
inferiority complex possible
a society that derives its stability
from the perpetuation of this complex
in a society that proclaims the
superiority of one way
race to the identical degree to which
that society creates difficulties for
him
he will find himself thrust into an
erotic situation so
it's not that people are are nuts it's
that society
and the way that it's set up and the
specificity of racial dynamics
is making people you know have suffer
from these
these matters and so he says what we
have to do then is combined action on
the individual
and the group right so
the black man should no longer be
confronted by the dilemma turn white or
disappear
but he should be able to take cognizance
of a possibility of existence and this
gets us to the existential approach that
we're going to look at
a little bit later another place that's
worth
bringing up in the text talking about
these dynamics
he he has this one line that's that's
quite uh
emblematic here he says you come
too late much too late there will always
be a world between
you and us the others total inability to
liquidate the past
once and for all so it's not as if we
can just
step ourselves into an abstract
situation where we
we're all color blind and the past
doesn't mean anything
and you know we all just recognize each
other as brothers and sisters or
whatever else
it's a world he says it stands between
us and it's a white world it's a world
that has been infused with valorizations
and meanings that's that's not so easy
to
slip out of a little bit
actually quite a bit later in the work
he
talks about the real white man waiting
for me after i've you know gone through
my
own sort of dynamics and so it's not as
if one can simply just wish
all of this away um earlier in the work
he talks about the difference between
two different levels of analysis a
philosophical
level which would be a level of the
basic needs of human reality and he says
i'm willing to work on the
psychoanalytic level
in other words the level of the failures
in the sense in which one speaks of
engine failures now is fanon sticking to
that
no he's actually carrying out an
analysis that is both philosophical and
psychoanalytic psychological at the very
same time
and these are informing each other we
should also talk
before we move on from psychoanalysis
about
what he does he critically engages
psychoanalytic uh
literature and key figures so you know
he talks about freud for example
telling you i think freud got this right
i think he got this part
wrong or he left this out he talks about
jung
he says that jung got something right
with the notion of the collective
unconscious
he just got it completely wrong in how
he actually describes
how the collective unconscious works and
what builds it
and totally overlooked the fact that he
was like drawing upon literature
of colonized peoples and had no problem
with that
he brings up adler who was a prominent
psychoanalyst of the time
whose view adler was one of these ego
psychologists
thought that the the goal is actually to
shore up the ego
against the id and the super ego and
allow us to live a more productive life
he talks about jacques lacan at at
certain points in some respects
positively in some respects negatively
um you know he he's uh engaging with
that i mentioned uh manoni who he brings
up and criticizes for having done
this analysis of uh people in madagascar
and then finally there's another author
jermaine
who he brings up and he really only has
positive things to say
about her analysis and it's very
interesting
because a lot of psychoanalysis focused
on
trauma as being the origin point
of psychological disorders and guru
talks about abandonment
and the role that non-affirmation has to
play something that was quite you know
recognized by say the the 60s and
70s in the psychoanalytic literature but
it took a while
uh they usually thought there had to be
some positive damage instead of
negative damage um and i wanted to bring
up
one example
of how he is appropriating this stuff so
this is uh in the the section
about psychopathology says
whenever i've read a psychoanalytic work
discussed problems with my professors or
talked with european patients
i've been struck by the disparity
between the corresponding schemas so
schemas are ways in which
things are understood and applied and
the reality that the negro presents
it has led me progressively to the
conclusion that there's a dialectical
substitution when one goes from the
psychology of the white man to that of
the black now he's not saying that you
know white brains and black brains are
different or anything like that he's
talking about this is
something that has come about because of
uh essentially
you know colonialism and and racism
and he says that a close study would
actually have to be divided into two
parts a psychoanalytic interpretation of
the life experience of the black man
and a psychoanalytic interpretation of
the
negro myth and he says reality prevents
such procedures the facts are much more
complicated so a psychoanalysis like
that carried out in here would have to
take
cognizance of all those complicated
facts
i mentioned that there is also an
existentialist approach there is a
complementarity here with the
psychoanalytic
approach and we have one figure who
actually gets referenced who combines
the both of them together and that would
be carl josper's who was a practicing
physician and psychologist and was also
a major philosopher and fanon actually
draws upon him
talking about the capacity to draw
useful information he's talking about in
terms of phenomenology at this point
useful information out of singular cases
by grasping what's essential in it
there's a lot of engagement with
jean-paul sartre
throughout the the work some of it
positive some of it critical
some of it appropriating things from
start some of de bever
as well even gabriel marcel comes in
his eter evoir being in having gets
mentioned
at a certain point um so you know
interesting example of this is where in
a footnote he's actually considering
something that sartre has to say and
contextualizing it he says
though sarts speculations on the
existence of the other
may in the other big caps may be correct
to the extent we must remember to which
being and nothingness describes an
alienated consciousness
their application to a black
consciousness proves fallacious
why because the white man is not only
the other but also the master whether
real or imaginary so he's not rejecting
sart's analysis wholesale and saying
this guy is totally off base or he's a
racist to reject him
he's saying no no the the uh
understanding that sart is working from
is
inadequate in certain respects we need
to fill in
gaps there's a number of different
i would say this fits into the
existential thing as well there's a
number of examination and rejection
of an appeal to racial archetypes one of
the
ways in which blacks were able to
you could say reorient themselves in
relation to
a white dominated world was to say
you're wrong when we
you say we don't have any history we
don't have any culture look at all these
examples look at and so they're engaging
in
archaeology they're engaging in recovery
of that history that people like hegel
had denied even existed when hegel says
africa
has no history that was the sort of
typical white stance for a long time and
it actually is still
among many people today all over the
world
and so fanon says okay i got into that
stuff
but it actually doesn't help
the situation and he talks about this
here we go he says
you know we encounter a white world then
can we re you know reconstitute
a black world he said from the opposite
end of the white world a magical negro
culture was hailing me
negro sculpture i began to flush with
pride was this our salvation i had
rationalized the world
and the world rejected me on the basis
of color prejudice
and so i threw myself into another world
and and you know we see this
today these these assertions that you
know all of the great philosophers were
secretly black or something like that
and finnon is saying that is totally
unhelpful that does not change the
situation
a bit a little bit later he's got a long
discussion in here
a little bit later he says my unreason
was countered with reason my reason with
real reason every hand was a losing hand
for me
i analyzed my heredity i made a complete
audit of my ailment i wanted to be
typically negro
and it was no longer possible i wanted
to be white that was a joke
when i tried on the level of ideas and
intellectual activity to reclaim my
negritude it was snatched away from me
proof was presented my effort was only a
term in the dialectic
and he goes on to quote senor and he
says
i felt i had been robbed of my my last
chance
uh and so a little bit later he says
orfeh noir is a is a date in the
intellectualization of the experience of
being black and then he criticizes
sartre again
and and he says
in terms of consciousness the black
consciousness is held out as an
absolute density is filled with itself a
stage preceding any invasion
any abolition of the ego by desire
and he says this is this is a mistake
this is a trap we need to get
out of that towards the end he he
actually
reapproaches this topic in by way
of a conclusion and he says
here we go
we don't want to be slaves of the past
on the one hand even the peloponnesian
war
belongs to me right he uses that as an
example
on the other hand all the discovery of
the existence of a negro civilization in
the 15th century
confers no patent of humanity on me
like it or not the past can in no way
guide me
in the present moment
he says the problem considered here is
one of time and we come back to this
complex problematic structure
those negroes and white men will be
disalienated who refuse to let
themselves be sealed away
in the materialized tower of the past
for many other negroes
in other ways disalienation will come
into being
through their refusal to accept the
present as definitive so
you know what are they refusing to
accept the president they're revolting
towards the future
but there's also the possibility of
recapturing a present
that is not one dominated by the
categories of of the past
and so moving through these these
dilemmas
this is really typically existentialist
getting
out of the complex almost
double bind or we might even say triple
bind if we sketched out the the
situation because there's a
another term in there yet in in the
analysis of consciousness this is
typically
existentialist it's not an assertion
that we can like snap our fingers
and suddenly make ourselves into beings
who we're not it is an understanding
that these structures do not have to
totally determine the present or the
future
and that we have to exercise our freedom
in order to do that
i do want to mention that that fanon
draws upon other sources
in this work as well which is you know
perfectly in accordance with the
psychoanalytic and existentialist
approaches if you look at the literature
of both
you'll see that being done so he looks
at
literature including contemporary
literature of his his
own time in which uh black white
situations are being depicted
you know literature provides us with a
window into psychology
he engages in critical analysis of
cultural products
ranging from films to brayer rabbit
stories to all sorts of other
things like tarzan for example he draws
upon lived experiences of himself
and those provided by others
as well in narratives and i
i want to close on one thing that i
think is is quite important to bring up
in terms
of this lived experience thing so
when he's criticizing manone the the
psychoanal
psychoanalytic author he says that
i'm not going to say that one cannot
enter into the lived experiences
of other people and understand them and
draw something out of them that's
actually
how we sometimes make progress how we
understand
the other manoni fails because he didn't
exercise
enough we might say empathy or
imagination or
you know faithfulness or anything like
that but we we can do that
we can understand our way by implication
into fun situation just as fanon can
understand his situation
can understand his way into the
situations of others
he wants to hold out that possibility
but he says it takes
work it takes effort it can't be
something
uh just taken for granted and we have to
continually engage in a dialectic of
seeing
whether we're getting things right i
would say that that's actually what what
psychoanalysis does when it's really
working well
and that's part of an existentialist
approach to the other
and so black skin white masks is in
effect drawing upon that
in order to make the case that what we
need is an analysis and then some sort
of action and response
that recognizes that it's not just a
matter of archetypes or anything like
that or you know
situations that are inevitable that
racism has deformed the personalities
and the orientations of so many people
and it does so not just through color
prejudice but also through economics
through a variety of other things that
have a bit more
sticking power that then get
internalized but
can be in some respect examined chipped
away at and overcome
you